so i had someone recently ask me a
question what's worse
bread or potato so this video is going
to talk about each one
let's start with potato now instant
potatoes
really spike your blood sugars fast
because you're
heating and processing this potato
down to this tiny little wafer-like
particle
so when you boil it or cook it you're
getting a
very fast spike in blood sugars
so that starch is completely broken down
so 97. now glucose is a hundred
so you're you're dealing with a product
that's very very close to pure
glucose then we get baked potato
that's 84. it's pretty high then we get
boiled potato which is 82.
the more you cook the potato the worst
effect it has on your blood sugars
if you consume a raw potato you're going
to be pretty much good to go in fact i'm
going to tell you right now
you can eat as many raw potatoes as you
want
okay but of course who's going to eat
raw potato it tastes
terrible but the point you need to know
is like
the cooking cooking starts breaking down
the starch into something that's higher
and higher on the glycemic
index now what about a sweet potato
see this word sweet right here there's
three times as much sugar
so if you have a choice definitely don't
do the sweet potato because it's
pretty sweet all right now if we switch
over here to
bread people think that whole wheat
bread is so much better
it's virtually the same on the glycemic
index 74.
but look at that this is actually lower
than potato
so right there this would be worse
but bread many times especially white
bread has bleach in there
which destroys your vitamin e it
depletes your
b vitamins especially vitamin b1
and also if you do whole wheat you're
going to have phytates in the brain
phytates or phytic acid will block zinc
creating a zinc deficiency and then you
have the gluten the protein in wheat
which will tear up your gut create a lot
of inflammation
and you may not find that the blood
sugars
spike immediately but you may find after
two hours they start going a little bit
higher even three
hours they start going even higher when
you're consuming
pasta you'll see a delayed spike in
blood sugars
so just because you don't see a quick
spike in blood sugars doesn't mean it's
not a problem
it's kind of delayed you'll see it a
post maybe
i don't know two or three hours but when
you get into potato you're going to see
an
instant spike what's interesting is that
an average american consumes
53 pounds of bread every single year
now the question is what is worse well
they're both kind of on the same level
because
this creates more of a blood sugar issue
but this will create
other issues like zinc deficiency gut
inflammation
vitamin e deficiencies and also a
vitamin b deficiency but other than that
i think it's perfectly healthy and i'm
being sarcastic
thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it